[Music]
you guys uh watch vh1 oh i love you
do you know about black ink crew no
okay is that like dave navarro
is that like a tattoo show with like
david or something is it on now yeah
it's on right now see i haven't watched
it in like years i was talking about
like there's a dude on there named
caesar emmanuel he's like one of the
stars of the show
he uh
got caught on video abusing his dogs oh
that's not good bro and he got fired
from the show what do you do kick his
bulldog or something like that can we
show it
nah what do you do to the dog can you
excuse me yeah he didn't kill him he's
just like like kicking around took a
folding chair smash [ __ ] oh my god grab
the dog toss through the middle cage
rolled the cage
if it's on patreon we can show it i mean
if you really want to see it look it up
it's not hard to find it's everywhere
but anyway the
that used to be the worst part of the
story and then like one day later he
does a video explaining himself
and he says he's he thinks it's a setup
oh
he's one of those guys
what do you mean he's like i didn't do
that he's like they're smearing my name
yeah he thinks he's beating i was trying
to smash a cockroach on the ground and
then they [ __ ] photoshopped the dog
in there his story is that he came home
his two dogs were fighting each other
like they were trying to kill each other
so he was separating them and also like
trying to get the dog to back down
because he said the dog started
attacking him
it doesn't look like that at all in the
videos but what it looked like and what
kind of dog they like exactly what i was
saying it just looks like you're just
[ __ ] around and was this like a right
away response or was this like a couple
days later here's the story
and the funny thing is it's from his own
[ __ ] ring cam
how did he get caught got out so that's
why he thinks like it's a setup he
thinks like somebody in the house maybe
his wife i don't know or like he didn't
explain how his own home ring cam video
got how did that get out that's funny
yeah that is maybe it is domestic what
if it is like a significant other that's
like don't [ __ ] hit our dogs like
that you ass you know that makes the
most sense who else he does he live with
that's the thing he didn't say but oh
they don't give us enough evidence to
work with man maybe it's someone that
works at his house for nothing that's a
whole point you can still work with this
can't you
you look like a detective right now come
on link everything together give me some
time give me some time all right you
guys keep giving me give me more
evidence yeah so that's his whole story
about why he was doing that to the dogs
but what he's doing is so like specific
all right this is what happened there it
is not much time at all
you didn't need much time
i love that no actual new information
all right so so he was he was [ __ ]
making a steak in the backyard right in
his eye cool and he [ __ ]
watson over there all right steak on the
counter he goes oh the corn he goes back
and then when he comes back in the dog
has a [ __ ] steak in his mouth he goes
you drop that right now and then
finally
he goes no you [ __ ] drop that [ __ ]
okay and he comes up and you won't drop
it so he grabs his chair and he tries to
throw it at him to scare him but it hits
the dog oh [ __ ] and then
yeah it was a misunderstanding it was a
misunderstanding but then now he's like
what do i do
they think i'm just
[ __ ] up abuser nobody ever believes me
nobody ever believes me so you believe
he's innocent no i don't believe that
but
[Laughter]
it's just a theory that he's putting out
there you guys
but you don't believe it he's not off
the hook with me you know i mean this is
real detective work yeah that's it's
like having m.91 as your lawyer and the
judge goes so your client's innocent he
goes i didn't say that not entirely wait
till the end wait till twist
you're gonna go what client
uh i'll tell you right after this
commercial break
yeah so you think we're back from the
commercial go ahead
um oh i i messed up as a detective
because i just realized i wasn't trying
to create a reason for him hitting the
dog i was trying to create a reason for
how the hell the footage got out and i
totally missed the mark there
[Laughter]
glossed over that yeah well ring
connects to wi-fi doesn't it yeah so
can't you hack somebody's wi-fi and be
able to get footage if you can log into
their ring account
i bet there's more than one other person
that has access to that account sure but
let's say like nobody is against him in
that house or he has like an employee
that maybe has access to the old
disgruntled employee with access to your
ring cam story
we need a shorter term for that man
because that is very common here why
don't we do this since you're the
detective he's going to watch the video
of it and we're going to see what he
thinks of the actual video okay it's
really short all right the detective
that came up with the plausible idea the
detective the most plausible the
detective uh this really matches
your theory the detective that already
thinks he's innocent
that one so that's that it's out there
outside
oh that's a very little dog
that's almost like a cat yeah both the
dogs are pretty small
so we should shed dogs so we really
shouldn't be hitting it with a chair why
is damon dash hanging out here damon
dash is there oh he just looks like a
big fan
hasn't happened yet i don't know if i
want to watch that you may not want to
watch it no you don't want to see it
yeah i don't like this kind of stuff i
get upset right and i'm going to say
kill him probably
i don't like this it starts to look like
a wwe thing
jesus christ bro
wow okay so that's multiple hits you we
don't want to we don't want to put this
on youtube no we don't want to put this
on anywhere and we're going to get our
channel destroyed there's more so that's
that that's half of it so he puts the
dog in his cage
wait what is he a sad and loyal dog
who's not even really what is he wearing
what is he wearing why is he wearing an
orange robe like a [ __ ] cage harry
chris then he just rolls the cage
okay so this is what happens um okay
we're okay we're in 1983. there's no
video footage i'm just a witness and i
have to explain to you what i just saw
okay uh
what looks like a garfield cat which is
actually a dog
walks out garfield yeah it's that color
it's an orange looking cat dog all right
so it's like this big maybe yeah
good dog and then a bald man walks
outside wearing shorts and what looks
like a t-shirt and it's like a gray
outfit or he's not he never at any point
denied that it was him like yeah he
walked out right the dog comes out
and then he goes
yeah i'm too fat i can't get him so it
goes back in the house or something the
dog's just confused and then like should
i go back in or what should i do right
he comes back out
he kicks the dog
like a football
the dog flies and then he comes back
because he thinks it's a game i don't
know why he gets a wwe
foldable chair we have one here evidence
yeah like that one right there evidence
yes evidence yes like that one right
he folds it
flat
he gets it and he smashes the dog and
the dog's like this size poor dog dog
right
no sound from the dog but he moves on
and he gets it and he hits it again like
a [ __ ] hockey
and then he goes back in the house
now all of a sudden he's in an orange
robe like a hare krishna right
the part you were very interesting
i don't know why
[ __ ] bright
matching robe
and then he grabs a cage
puts the dog in the cage locks it rolls
it downhill
i know there's a cage downhill with the
dog
in it i i don't know why there's no two
dogs it's just one dog oh that's the
only dog there's i don't know where the
other dog is
yeah he had there's those are two
different dogs but they just look the
same okay because oh it looked like the
one he hit with the [ __ ] thing and
then when he wore the orange robe it was
a different dog that was like more white
a little bit bigger and maybe spotted or
something like that can i see what it
looks like
is there a picture of him
well can we watch his video forget this
fool's [ __ ]
uh
alibi or whatever the [ __ ] explanation
he's absolutely full of [ __ ] very very
much so it looked like he was just
attacking a helpless animal yeah it's
[ __ ] up wow yeah so we're not going to
show it on youtube because you know we
don't want this channel to be destroyed
so at the end of the day i was trying to
back the door down i was honestly trying
to skim and not what time was i trying
to abuse this
yeah right bro that was pure it went out
of his way it did extra [ __ ] man come on
that's absolute [ __ ] yeah this guy's
a piece of [ __ ] it was bad footage
though to be honest because i saw a fat
bald white dude and then the guy here's
a black guy
oh you thought it was a white guy in the
video he's not a good detective man
it's the ring camera footage dude
it must have been night vision that's
what it was you know one of the funniest
uh it does what does the dog look like
detective like garfield
[Laughter]
well they use lasagna
the police sketch is just a comic
he's like
that's it that's the one one of the
funniest comments i read on uh like uh
the social media posts about him
was uh so he at no point denied that he
like that was him in the video
but the top comment that everyone's
loyaling is someone went how do they
know that's him
he's admitting to yeah
that's not even the part that he was
saying like you can't defend people
doing that [ __ ] someone saw how do they
know that's him how do they even know
and everyone's like are you [ __ ]
serious
i mean i would've
that's a detective
yeah people are so slow like that's not
even the thing in question he's
man so his rationale is that he was
trying to split them up and then he was
trying to back the dog down which i
guess meant that the dog was by hating
him with a [ __ ] phone did you say the
dog is hella small yeah it didn't even
look like yeah it was small it was like
this big and there's enough audio that
you could probably hear if it was
growling or barking because you could
hear the chair dude you could hear that
clear as day yeah it's like
it was kind of an excuse i think it's
it's it's better that you guys didn't
see it and i painted the picture because
then it's it's sort of it like made it
comedy even though he painted it as a
white man yeah
but when i watched it though it's pretty
sad
it is pretty sad yeah because i used to
have a dog that size yeah you know did
you have a chair that size too oh man
he had the orange robe i think the guy
should
probably go on wwe and get slam [ __ ]
with that chair multiple times
i think so just break his [ __ ] legs
over and over over and over dude it is
hari krishna robes
set him on fire put him in a cage roll
him down mountain once they find out
it's him though
stupid
[Music]
you